you named a lot of your uh you know you
obviously you have two kids man tell us
about uh
i have four kids one kid all right okay
but you have you named a couple
albums or a couple of song names after
your kids right well
the album that i just dropped the first
album i dropped was isla
and i named that after my daughter and
the album that i'm about to drop now is
nan kazu
after my son and the names are so
different man
well they both they both are a big name
yeah like isla
it's like to to critique to make better
and like a like a epiphany a great
awakening
and my daughter did all of those things
for me in kaza
it means like powerful like a great
treasure yeah
yeah that's what he is to me how do you
feel like that with your kids mike
you know obviously mike's got seven kids
my kids
yeah that's interesting i'm a ketchup i
have to be very careful with my kids
because i forget sometimes
i'm me and um i forget that i'm mike
tyson that guy that over
powering father and stuff so i got to be
very
gentle with them because they may take
it personal yeah cause i do remember
i do remember yesterday we're talking
mike and it's like with mike because
he's you know he's such a public figure
that uh
you know he walks on the street people
you know people surround him
and what happens and i i was very
heartfelt with mike was saying is that
his kids
you know it's because it happens to me
every once in a while but like his kids
are kind of like they leave and
everybody else is like there's like why
are you guys leaving man
yeah what i'm saying like they're not
used to all these people they always
want to be with me they don't want to be
all these people just
it just it just don't rub them well they
feel isolated they don't feel like
they're part of me
right yeah and that's not that's not a
good feeling do you ever feel like that
as
a public figure man like having well
working on this album right now i've
been traveling everywhere
and just working wherever i go like i'm
an energy person i'm not trying to sound
like a tree hugger or anything like that
but
i'm an energy person if the energy good
i'm there
and i've been away from my children and
sometimes i feel like
man i'm a bad father because i'm away
from my children that's the hardest
thing for me
is being away from my children i don't
like that either
yeah i don't like it like i didn't have
a father growing up
so i you know just i was always locked
up so i never saw my family much i was a
[Music]
kid